as I've said just my personal preference
the way I remember which ones which is I
just think alphabetically so domain and
then range that's alphabetical order
which matches up to x and y which is
also alphabetical order if that doesn't
ring a bell and you prefer to think
about pizza dough which is Thor main
which goes there just whatever works for
you okay door main now the reason why
I'm talking about this just quickly now
is because when you are stating domain
and range there are lots of good ways to
actually articulate it to write it on
this one particular way but they don't
want you to write it and I'll hopefully
I'll explain why there is just example
to pick out is um is this guy this is
what I grasp we didn't look at linear
parabolic exponential florid making
trips
okay just really quickly and this is of
course it's neither of those it's a it's
a high polygraph right so this is a
hyperbola if you want to be really
really um fancy bad this is not just a
hyperbola it's a rectangular hyperbola
and you would say nothing about that
looks like a rectangle relax you will
learn about our hyperbola in the future
they don't retain you like you've seen
water but this question of how to state
domain a range becomes important when
you have a look at this guy because of
course there are some features this
thing off my graph namely the asymptotes
right so you put them in and because of
the the marvelous symmetry of this shape
the once you've got the domain is pretty
much state of the race
when you say the domain it's kind of
tempting to say well being the beyond
the equation of the vertical asymptote
is X equal to zero it's kind of tempting
to say well you know it's everywhere but
X is not equal to zero okay now you
absolutely absolutely must not say that
this is the domain okay because this is
the opposite of the domain this is where
the graph doesn't exist this is the
restriction right so when they say
what's the domain they're asking you for
where does X exist
okay you are saying where X does not
exist so the parallel i/o at the example
I always give is when people say oh uh
you know just trying to get to know
someone what's what do you do for your
job and you're like well I'm not a
lawyer I'm not a doctor but what are you
okay you're not answering the question
okay so don't say what is it that you
can't still use this phrase if you might
so let me show you a couple of ways that
I think are acceptable uh one way you
can say is of all real values of X but
but X is not equal to zero okay I think
that's okay I wouldn't use the word
accept right because when you say it's
like what I think about the way the word
except this baby works okay except means
what are the exceptions okay so for
example if I say okay um you can have
you you know somewhat sabor stationary
from inside okay you can have anything
in this bag accepts my red pen right now
what that means is I'm saying this is a
thing and you can't have it right I'm
saying this is my red pen and you're not
allowed to touch it okay so the thing
the way that I would say what are you
not allowed to touch the thing you're
not allowed to touch is x equals zero
right that's what you're not allowed to
touch so if I were to use the word
except I would say all revalue of X
except for x equals zero that's the only
one you can't have right I feel it to be
confusing because you're trying to say
it's not that which is
I prefer the word but okay now um all
real values of X as you've said before
mappers unions are always looking for
shortcut ways of saying things okay so
another way of saying all real values of
x you can use this notation you can say
now I'm going to give you the full on
proper one okay which is you open a
curly brace that indicates I'm talking
about a set of values not just one value
you say a set of values of X such that X
is real right so this is a symbol for
real and X is not equal to zero so if
you want to go the fully symbolic fancy
technical route that's the way to do it
it's like even use words now that weighs
fine in fact you'll even see some text
which you say it like that I'm not
really a fan of it because it's so tight
it's unnecessarily technical okay so
even though it's the most concise and if
I were writing my own notes I'd write
that because the fastest I don't
recommend it because you're just as
easily cut yourself up and like is it a
colon or a car or is that what you were
just confuse yourself there's two ways
here's what I think is the best way in
some ways it's the easiest really if I
gave you some other kind of function
like say uh like a simple I gave me the
unit circle right you would say this is
not the unit circle but you would say
okay it's between negative 1 and 1
there's the domain okay in other words
we use in a quality language to stay to
stay to donate and to state the range
okay we do this for every other function
so why not do it for a hyperbola the
easiest way is to just code from left to
right okay
what's this pun this is on the left this
part is X is less than zero X is less
than Z okay but that's not the early
part that's okay I'm not a part namely X
is crazy row okay I really like this way
of doing it it seems to be
estrogen but it's consistent with the
ways we write to evade in other cases
right and also one of the really neat
things that gets out is the fact that
there are two branches therefore you're
gonna have two parts of the inequality
really simple right if you get wieder
crazier other functions or relations
which you will get you just get you know
however many branches you have you'll
have a little chorus what do you the
quality okay so I think that's a
simplistic best way to you and naturally
arranged in this case with me everything
exactly the same but wise mister dances